disney princesses have dreamy gowns we
would have loved to wear to prom
but wait they're not actually
historically accurate
this is how their hair makeup and
outfits should have looked
when we think of belle we picture her
stunning yellow ball gown
yes it's fancy but it's not actually
fancy
enough beauty and the beast was set in
18th century france when women were
living their best lives through
fashion so beast would have given belle
something that made a much bigger impact
let's start with the skirt wealthy women
wore skirts so wide
they had to be held up by a frame
underneath all the volume was on the
hips
it actually made passing through a
doorway very difficult
belle's corset should be tied at the
back with straps giving her an even
tinier waist the whole outfit needs to
be adorned with bows
frills lace and ruffles more is more in
18th century france
accessories were extra too belle should
wear a velvet choker decorated with
flowery bows to draw attention to her
neck
she should also hold an elaborate fan
encrusted with gems and gold embroidery
this was used for flirting techniques
back in the day so belle should walk
down that staircase holding her fan
up over the bottom half of her face at
least they got those elbow length gloves
right
finally belle's hair is far too subtle
she should have a huge
dude powdered white that powdering
extends down to her face and chest with
stand out blush on top
but when it comes to standout makeup
mulan's your girl
disney based mulan on an ancient chinese
ballad set during the northern wei
dynasty
disney got a lot right for her outfit
for meeting the matchmaker
but we need to make some tweaks first up
those long sleeves
they're called wang xiao and they're a
little bit too long
let's shorten them just beyond mulan's
hands as for her shawl we need to do the
same
women would have worn silk shawls like
this but they wouldn't have stretched so
low as to touch the ground
let's shorten that too we also need to
shorten mulan's hemline
that would reveal her footwear fashion
professor beth charleston told glamour
magazine that she would be wearing a
slipper shoe with upturned toes
we need to get real about mulan's jade
necklace although wealthy women would
have worn it mulan's family would not
have been able to afford that chunky
piece of expensive jewelry
so we need to swap that out for a
necklace where the green beads are made
from glass
and spread out on a long thin chain
mulan's hair comb would have been made
from kingfisher feathers so we need to
make sure that's blue
as for her hair she should have worn it
in a more elaborate double bun
worn side to side what do you think of
the differences between these two looks
[Music]
we're considering how jasmine should
have looked had aladdin been set in the
late 17th early 18th century in the
middle east
according to historian professor aisha
baltha julubramer
this was during the lifetime of the
story's creator and most of jasmine's
look is
way off the mark that top is way too
revealing
she certainly wouldn't have been
flashing her belly jasmine would have
worn a corset under her outfit instead
as for her pants they're actually pretty
accurate but she would have worn a dress
over the top with a belt around it
the imperial and expensive colors of red
and green were the most popular choices
for wealthy women
so we need to switch out jasmine's teal
blue color palette
jasmine sure loved her bling but she
would have worn even more
we're talking bracelets necklaces and a
tiara
when it comes to headwear disney got
that right jasmine wore a shawl over her
hair when she was out but she could have
also worn a more delicate embroidered
tool over the top
her shoes are also correct as is her
heavy coal eyeliner
pie yourself on the back for that disney
now it's time to discover what disney
got right
and wrong with ariel's style the little
mermaid was published by hans christian
anderson
in 1837. so we're looking to the fashion
of europe in the 1830s for an accurate
look
and we're certainly glad we are because
that was a seriously
extra time for fashion when ariel dines
with eric her pink gown is pretty puffed
up already
but it's just not big enough to match
the dramatic outfits of the time
those sleeves need to get even puffier
she needs a wide collar too
ariel should have an intricate bodice in
an upside down triangle pointing down
towards the high nipped waist plus a
wide belt with a gold buckle
ariel's wide skirt should be held out at
the back thanks to a bustle underneath
and it should fall just to above her
ankles the 1830s were big on lavish
jewelry with bracelets featuring a cameo
and long chains that wound around the
waist necks shoulders and even the hair
add in brooches and elaborate drop
earrings and you can see how exuberant
fashions of the period reflected the
romantic movement
as for ariel's hair women like to wear
theirs in ringlets
so we need to switch ariel straight due
for a mass of perfectly tight curls
falling down around her shoulders
aurora also needs to take a visit to the
hair salon for her historically accurate
look
we love how the fairies flora and
meriwether argued over
what color aurora's dress should be but
they should have been more concerned
about the style of her gown
sleeping beauty is set in the 14th
century and disney got the long sleeves
right but we need to make a fair few
changes to nail that historical look
aurora needs two layers
over a tailored dress with tight fitting
bodice and sleeves she needs a second
loose dress like a robe
this should be worn open with a long
train as for accessories
aurora needs brooches to decorate her
fitted bodice
lucky for her she's got that wide
forehead and blonde hair that were so
fashionable back then
but aurora needs to style her locks
differently she should have braids by
her ears and
veil over her hair at least she's got
the on trend crown
already do you prefer these princesses
original looks or their more
historically accurate outfits
which princess is your favorite sound
off in the comments below and hit that
thumbs up button if you love the disney
princesses as much as we do
thanks for watching
[Music]
you